jacques brel jadis est ce que vous
pensiez qu'un jeu vous feriez cinéma
maintenant qu'est-ce qui vous avez envie
de jouer ce film de jouer ce rôle ce
caillou qu'est ce qui vous avait attiré
en lui comment pouviez-vous deviner
qu'ils s'arrêtent un grand acteur de
cinéma il avait été frappé par ses
qualités de d'expression directe c'est
en plus c'était un rôle d'instituteurs
d'un instituteur de plain pied avec les
enfants et brel à cette qualité il a ce
don de s'émerveiller qui est au fond la
qualité principale de l'enfant ce dont
s'est indigné aussi quand je les propose
est bien entendu il ya eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de trouble parce que brel
l'acteur de sa surprenait tout le monde
bat elle s'était d'abord avant tout un
chanteur un spécialiste du music hall
une technique tout à fait différente de
la nôtre et les producteurs était
inquiet moi j'étais semble totalement
sans inquiétude et pour une autre raison
parce qu'il est aviateurs je ne vois pas
et bien je vous expliquais c'est un
homme qui a un sens de la discipline
un sens de l'espace qui sait ce qu'il
doit faire au moment où il doit le faire
qu'il ya des réflexes d'une extrême
précision et j'étais absolument sûr que
en m'adressant à presles aviateurs
j'obtiendrai de lui que au bénéfice de
bras l acteur il oublie by le chanteur
pendant 15 ans j'étais sur scène en tour
de chant et on est obligé de toutes les
formes et de toutes à grandir il a fallu
film a fallu essayer de désapprendre ça
aura prendre c'est pas tellement
difficile mais désapprendre set
extrêmement difficile j'étais obligé de
faire tout en exagérant sur une scène
alors que onze années là vous avez joué
simple bonjour j'aimerais jouer j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu
qu'est ce qui vous a plus le rôle dont
l'histoire résumée la en deux mots on
parle d'injustice
c'est vers institutet c'est un
instituteur c'est un instituteur qui est
bien vue semble-t-il bien c'est un type
normal enfin avec ce que ça de
gentillesse et aussi un peu de mal à ces
nobles enfin dans l'ensemble qui est
accusée brusquement ce village où il est
bien vu il est accusé de tentative de
viol en fin de show sauce à part des
gamines pour des raisons différentes
et toute la population se retourne
contre lui on croit les fillettes en eau
propre lui révèle le rôle de
l'instituteur
comment l'avez vous travaillez vous en
êtes vous un bib et est ce que vous êtes
allé par exemple dans l'ue n'entend pas
que vous nous venons maintenant parce
que l'instituteur pour moi c'est
j'attache pas beaucoup d'importance à la
fonction des hommes s'attache beaucoup
plus important sur la manière dont il
m'a semblé urgent que ce type soit un
brave type mais il aurait pu le
garagiste dans mon esprit
comprenez c'est différent un brave type
intel est difficile d'en bravia un côté
comment dirais-je non pas bête non
yakoutie l'unité soit c'est faire avec
comme on dit vulgairement un brave type
est un type qui connaît ses limites ou
qui sait qui s'est résigné c'est quand
même assis sur une partie de ses rêves
et alors l'autre partie ils plantent des
fleurs dessus pour que ça paraisse plus
plus important plus luxueux
le film apporte-t-il quelque chose et si
oui quoi le dans le cadre d'un qui l'a
jamais fait donc monsieur ça apporte
quelque chose d'abord je suis aperçu que
depuis 15 ans était bigrement isoler la
chanson isole ont fait ces chansons ont
fait la musique fait les paroles on est
tout seul alors que le cinéma redécouvre
l'équipe j'avais l'impression d'avoir de
nouveaux 18 ans joue au football ne soit
le l'éclairage d'importance le troisième
tchèque est malade mais tout ça tout ça
ça compte tous âges ou alors on retrouve
l'équipe ça c'est formidable
comment voyez vous votre avenir est ce
que vous voudriez refaire du cinéma j'en
sais rien ça dépend ça dépend
essentiellement des histoires que
qui sera content de ce mois ci si un
film peut apporter une seconde de de
rêve de joliesse ou de ou de révolte
dans le sens où je trouve que les hommes
ne sont pas ces révoltés c'est le rêve
qui va vers la dignité pas du tout vers
le ver le sens et je peux donner un coup
de main petits à cette forêt voix cette
voix cette dignité
je plonge immédiatement aurais je marche
si c'est pour faire du cinéma pour faire
du cinéma ça ne m'intéresse pas